an investment firm creates a graph
showing the performance of a specific
stock over 12 months over the course of
the years the price of the stock rising
falling or staying the same so over this
axis right over here the horizontal axis
they have month by month and we move
forward in time July August September
October and in this axis the vertical
axis we have the price so for example in
July the price of this the price of this
stock was a little over ten dollars then
in August it moved up to looks like
around eleven dollars and then we could
keep going month by month and this type
of graph right over here is called a
line graph because you have the data
points for each month and then we
connected them with a line and the
reason why we connect them with the line
is to really see if there's some kind of
a trend here to really show that these
that you have something that's moving
from one price to another and so lime
grass tend to be used when you have
something that's changing over time now
that out of the way let's actually
answer their question over the course of
the year is the price of the stock
rising falling or staying the same so on
a month-to-month basis you have for
example from July to August the price
went up then from August to September
the price went down then it went up for
two months then it went down for a month
then it went up for a couple of more
months and it went really up from
February to March went all the way up to
almost seventeen dollars then it went
down again and then it went then it kept
going up again but they're asking us not
you know did it go up every month
they're saying over the course of the
year over the course of the year is the
price of the stock rising falling or
staying the same and if you go from July
which is where our data starts right
over here our price was around ten
dollars and even though there were a few
months where it where it went down the
overall trend is that the price is going
up the overall trend is that the price
is going up and you can even see that in
July it was $10 and then by June of the
next year it was approaching on and it
looks like it's about almost a little
over $16 maybe almost $17 so it actually
had gone up a lot they don't give us
July of the next year but the overall
trend is definitely on the upwards
direction right over here and you can
see it just visually by looking at this
line graph even those are a few bumps
that go down the overall direction is
upward